thank you
sovereign
yes in fact now moving on now since
since you've just said that now and by
the way let me just tell you something
about juice let me answer this question
the prophet Muhammad you've read his
Sera married a Jewish woman
in the Quran which is a religious book
which we follow that you said you've
read yes the prophet Moses has been
mentioned no less than 136 times
the prophet Moses you're talking about
Jews
so you're going to let me speak or is
this as are you afraid of the are you
afraid the Quran specifically says about
Jewish people is that they were actually
chosen people it does say this actually
he affirms that narrative yeah it says
yes
Mischief Makers they commit facade and
therefore according to 502 I'm 33 they
shall be killed actually
you just said you just said according to
532 and 533 it says that Jews are
Mischief Makers let me recite for you
let me recite you asked me to assign I
will recite from memory 532 and 5 33.
are you ready for it and I'm gonna do
you know what's interesting about this
very verse it's gonna humiliate him even
worse
excuse me this is I'm saying in Arabic
and translate in English
we have written upon the children of
Israel
office
whoever kills a person listen listen to
me it's what 5 32 says he mentioned 5
32. excuse me let me finish I'm
mentioning what he mentioned 5 32. I
mentioned 532 whoever kills a person the
Quran is saying this whoever kills a
person for other than corruption in the
land or for them killing themselves then
it's like they've killed all of
humankind the Quran is saying that if
you kill one person it's like you killed
everyone woman
and whoever Saves a Life it's as if he
saved all of the humankind the very
verse that you are trying to quote
misquote in my presence how dare you
hold on hold on the very verse that you
try to misquote in my presence is
actually a verse that tells you that if
you kill one person whether they are
Muslim Christian Jewish or any other
thing it's like you've killed all the
human beings on the earth and if you
save one human being it's like you've
saved all the human being of the earth
so you lied about the Quran and anyone
can I will check me now excuse me anyone
can fact check me now how many phones
are here go ahead and go your phone go
to chapter five go to verse number 32
and you'll see what I've just said so
are you going to apologize for
misfortunately you're lying and your
life
get out of here okay oh yeah yeah he ran
away for a second just go ahead yeah how
are you gonna apologize for this quote
in the Quran in my presence of the
presence of the people yeah
may I answer now hey yeah good yeah you
are a very good Muslim liar okay no
problem anybody
I encourage anyone to look up this verse
and what you will see is killing someone
because this person excuse me are you
are you Muslim you're not Muslim yeah
all right can you go on the Quran go
Google chapter 5 verse 32. anybody do it
and you can see can you go ahead and do
it fact check me now yeah
yeah sure anyone get the Quran can you
shut up no get in English because you
know you know you are a liar and you're
a liar
please shut up and let me answer okay
unless foreign
are you watching my videos again
pause that and do something for you
first Islam net is establishing a
Scandinavian Mega mosque and Tower
Center in Oslo the fastest growing city
in Europe do you want to share on that
reward click the link below and donate
now
foreign
[Music]
so who was right and who was wrong
was he a liar was he a liar yes or no
one want to make you believe that that's
it thank you my friend me Chief is how
are we done here now now let me just
I'll give you I'm going to put into a
kind of of a political opposition
against Islam is Mischief it's a
corruption in the land okay thank you
foreign
are you Irish are you Norwegian I don't
even know what kind of accent that is
I think she's attracted to me
how could she not me when she's hanging
around this guy all day and then she
sees some six foot seven individual it
comes in Norway and discovers the whole
thing oh I will how would you explain
how would you explain the prophets
Muhammad saying man
whoever kills a non-combatant
disbeliever
he will not be he will not smell the
fragrance of Heaven how do you
understand that you can understand it by
saying looking at the Hadith that when
Muhammad was asked well uh why why do we
how do you understand this Hadith
you have to look at the holidays no no
how do you understand this Hadith that's
my question you have to look at that how
do you understand this no no how do you
understand this Muhammad said that um
yeah when yeah we attack this innocent
little village at night okay
respect me I'm answering you no I want
this Hadith you're going somewhere else
um the prophet said they are of them
meaning the children and the women are
influenced just go ahead and kill them
I'm aware of the Hadith yeah I'm aware
of that yeah okay I'm more of the Hadith
I'm aware of that and it doesn't because
if you understand that Hadith to mean
that the prophet salallahu said that he
to kill the movement of children he
didn't in fact let me tell you the
hadees actually States when he saw the
woman on the battlefield that was dead
and I'll say in Arabic and then
translate it he says
it wasn't for her to be killed and we
know why because we like to take slaves
sex slaves so whenever a woman is killed
you just contradicting yourself no
you're contradicting yourself
[Applause]
which one is it now which one is it
slaves or killing which one is it
because you said I have to kill them and
you know that you know
I was quoting and it was making it
illegal to
six pillars of creed not knowing the
prophet's full name not being qualified
in any University even in your country
being a jobless man that you are and let
me ask you a question even though you're
all those things and let me ask you your
expert opinion just ask questions you
don't have to harass people just ask for
Quran States in chapter 60 verse 8.
that God does not deny you does not tell
you not to deal justly and kindly with
those disbelievers that don't take you
out of your home or don't don't try and
kill you that you deal justly with them
you'll justly yeah and that you're good
with them because God loves the just now
this is a verse in the Quran that's not
abrogated how do you explain this verse
us well looking at the word justlyn
explains everything because what's just
in Islam that's Sharia is
um
something more Humane so yeah
there's two opposite words one word is
to be good with them the other one
and to be just with them so being good
with them just how do I be good and just
with a disbeliever and kill them at the
same time can you tell me how you can
you can kill them if you follow for
example 532 or 100 109 words I think you
don't know what you're talking about you
know that I'm right
means
I'm explaining to you you're incorrect
about this so these kinds of
intellectual Expeditions this kind of
intellectual activism couldn't be done
wouldn't be done without your charitable
donations because this is an integral
aspect of the dawah that we challenge
those kinds of views that we're seeing
in the Western World which makes
International media now we have a chance
to respond
Islam net has established an entire
Center
doing the work educating people of Islam
crushing islamophobia are we going to be
the people we are a junction out as a
community are we going to be the people
who are going to
contribute to this course
what are we going to be stingy Allah
says in the Quran
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
foreign
that you people
you people have been called
to given the sake of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to give charity in the sake of
Allah
so amongst you will be those who will be
stingy
and whoever is stingy miserly
he's only being stingy upon his own self
and Allah is the rich one the one free
of need and you and me you Allah says
are the poor ones
and if you turn away yes
Allah will replace us replace me in you
replace you Allah says with the people
other than you and they will not be like
you
thank you
what do you think
so so add something else yeah okay
so the best way to prove to yourself
and to Allah that you're not among the
stingy ones the miserly ones the weak
ones
is that you give in the sake of Allah
you have an opportunity the link is
below just click it what's it gonna take
10 seconds of your time 15 20 seconds
you wouldn't even use that kind of time
to blow your nose on a handkerchief
the time is now
click the link